bonjour c'est une conférence de presse
peu particulière ce qu'on est en plein
milieu du week end de la toussaint mais
nous avons quand même tenu à la tenir
guillaume et moi alors on va vous parler
d'abord de la mobilisation des
fédérations des républicains des 5 et 6
novembre
nous faisons une opération sous
l'impulsion de notre président laurent
wauquiez il s'appelle redonnons un cap à
la france ça sera un week-end de
mobilisation de l'ensemble de nos
fédérations et dans toutes les
fédérations
il y aura des activités des tables
rondes des cafés politiques des
opérations portes ouvertes etc etc
et puis mais j'y reviendrais des
tractages de 4,4 tracts à paris pour
ceux que ça intéresse particulièrement
le siège des républicains sera ouvert et
la fédération de paris organisera samedi
matin une des tables rondes thématiques
sur la sécurité défense la salle de
shoot les voies sur berges et le statut
de paris
alors nous serons amenés à distribuer
donc nos adhérents vont distribuer 4
tracts 3 tracts thématique la lutte
contre le terrorisme contre la lutte
contre le terrorisme mettre fin au
laxisme des forêts classes moyennes stop
aux impôts
luttons contre l'immigration illégale
maîtrisant nos frontières et enfin un
tract pour inciter les gens à voter aux
primaires
les 20 et 27 novembre 2016 votez pour
votre information soit parfaite
le parti a fait deux magazines des
républicains sur le vote aux primaires
le premier paru en juin spécial primaire
et celui qui vient de paraître et qui a
été envoyé à l'ensemble de nos adhérents
votez et faites voter nous avons aussi
les avait en tout cas deux deux superbes
affiches redonnant à capa la france
bonjour nadège tu vas bien enfin je
recommence tout ce que je me fonde sur
une dépêche afp sur ce truc là
bon je vais rennais déjà prêt tant pis
donc on parlait de l'opération redonner
un cap à la france qui est une opération
qu'on va dire le week-end prochain 5 et
6 novembre où l'ensemble des fédérations
du parti devront tracts et faire des
opérations portes ouvertes etc
pour ce pour susciter un mouvement
important pour faciliter le vote à la
primaire pour inciter les gens les voter
à la primaire
et pour pour essayer de continuer à
recueillir des dons et des adhésions au
parti
guillaume je te laisse la parole merci
frédéric donc à presser ses points
évidemment important présenté par
frédéric sur la volonté de notre
formation politique d'inciter au maximum
l'ensemble des sympathisants et des
électeurs intéressés par cette primaire
à se mobiliser sur des thématiques
précises nous souhaitions ce matin vous
parlez de trois sujets d'actualité
importants qui préoccupe de compatriotes
le premier sujet c'est évidemment jusque
nous en sommes asphyxiés du matin au
soir et du soir au matin sept jours sur
sept ce vaudeville département de tout
le gouvernement de tous les membres du
gouvernement du président de la
république du premier ministre de ses
ministres des parlementaires qu'il soit
frondeurs ou pas frondeurs une véritable
tragi-comédie au sommet de l'état sur
tous les sujets chaque jour l'un est
loyal le lundi ne l'est plus le mercredi
le redevient au nom de la loyauté
gouvernemental de vendredi avant de
repenser à la nécessaire liberté qui est
la sienne je pense à à manuel valls
et tout ça sans doute pour cacher une
inquiétude profonde et un échec
monumental
sur les questions par exemple économique
vous savez que cette semaine comme c'est
le cas depuis un certain nombre de temps
à l'assemblée comme au sénat
la thématique du budget de la france qui
engagent l'avenir de notre pays et
l'avenir de nos enfants
ce budget va être débattu par la
représentation nationale dans un
contexte absolument désertique sur la
question du chômage
un million cent soixante mille chômeurs
de plus depuis l'accession de françois
hollande au pouvoir sur la question de
la croissance
elle nous était promise à une hauteur de
1,5 point pour 2016 quand on regarde
précisément les chiffres 0,6 de hausse
au premier trimestre 0,1 de baisse au
second trimestre et 0,2 de hausse au
troisième trimestre à l'heure où on
parle
nous sommes à 0,7 ce qu'elle fait dire
enfin à monsieur sapin qui n'est pas à
une fourberie près ce qui a fait dire à
monsieur sapins sont vendredi ce sera
peut-être très compliqué d'atteindre le
fameux 1,5 nécessaires à une
présentation au moins équilibré dans la
forme du budget de la france
on peut y ajouter toutes les fourberies
de monsieur sapin sur la question du
projet de loi de finances de la sécurité
sociale et du reste puisqu'il nous a
annoncé un rééquilibrage des comptes
maquiller oubliant de dire que la
principale source de recettes
supplémentaires provenaient de la
courageuse réforme des retraites portée
par nicolas sarkozy eric woerth en 2010
et ce ne sont pas les annonces de
françois hollande sur le milliard
supplémentaire attribué au quartier
plus que les 400 millions d'économies
annoncées dans ce budget très loin des
attentes de nos concitoyens dont je vous
rappelle qu'il met en priorité pour les
mois et les années qui viennent
par delà toutes les autres thématiques
la nécessaire baisse des dépenses
publiques et nous souhaitions à
l'occasion de la présentation de ce
budget insincère totalement improvisée
absolument décadent sans même parler du
matraquage fiscal
les 50 milliards de hausse d'impôts
depuis l'accession de françois hollande
au pouvoir nous souhaitions nous
rappeler les propositions des
républiques qui sont bien plus
audacieuses et courageuses et
nécessaires
nous ce que nous proposons par exemple
est une véritable réforme de l'assurance
maladie avec un peu plus de 30 milliards
d'économies sur l'ensemble du
quinquennat avec une baisse par exemple
de 76 à 73 % du taux de remboursement
des médicaments
ces 15 milliards d'économies sur la
question des retraites et de l'égalité
entre le public et le privé
cette égalité qui trône au fronton de
nos mairies et qui est bafouée par la
gauche française depuis des années
qu'ils refusent d'inscrire dans les
faits et dans la loi l'égalité absolue
entre le système public et le système
privé sur la question des jours de
carence sur la question des retraites
ces 15 milliards d'économies surtout
qu'un quinquennat
si nous avions le courage et nous
l'aurons de porter cette réforme c'est 4
milliards d'euros d'économies sur la
dégressivité indispensable des
allocations chômage ou encore autre
exemple un milliard d'économies si nous
avions le courage de supprimer l'aide
médicale d'état qui bénéficient
aujourd'hui exclusivement aux
clandestins
et quand on entend le président de la
république vendredi dernier sur la
question de la croissance
osé le mot nous sommes sur un sentier de
la croissance
ce devait être en 2012 l'autoroute de la
croissance puis la grande route de la
croissance puis le large chemin de la
croissance
nous en sommes aujourd'hui au sentier et
chacun sait que demain nous irons dans
une impasse de la croissance françois
hollande a mené la france sur le plan
économique sur le plan budgétaire
sur le plan financier dans une impasse
et les français n'en peuvent plus de ces
tours de passe passe de cette union
illusionnisme de ses clowneries parce
que c'est comme ça que les français le
ressentent
et on pourrait dire y compris sur les
questions du chômage que françois
hollande est devenu le véritable david
copperfield du chômage puisqu'il a la
capacité incroyable et inédite de faire
disparaître des chômeurs d'un mois à
l'autre les mettant par exemple sur la
voie de garage
très souvent de formation dont on sait
hélas que trop peu souvent elles
débouchent sur un véritable emploi avant
de revenir dans les statistiques du
chômage 6 millions de chômeurs en france
huit millions six cent mille français
qui vivent sous le seuil de pauvreté un
million cent soixante mille chômeurs de
plus depuis 2012 une croissance en berne
des impôts qui ont explosé tel est le
triste bilan économique budgétaire et
financier du président de la république
et de l'ensemble de son gouvernement
deuxième sujet que nous souhaitions
abordé ce matin avec frédérique entre
deux moments d'actualité
c'est la décision du conseil d'état qui
est attendu vous savez sur la présence
autoriser ou non des crèches dans les
bâtiments publics décision du conseil
d'état qui sera rendu mercredi prochain
à la suite d'une position plutôt
courageuse du rapporteur du conseil
d'état qui a demandé il y a une semaine
à ce que ces crèches puisse être
autorisé dans les bâtiments publics sous
un nombre un certain nombre de
conditions nous souhaitons nous les
républicains qui à l'occasion de cette
décision le conseil d'état puisse
réaffirmé haut et fort avec autorité
avec force dans un contexte de crise et
d'inquiétudes que la laïcité n'est pas
l'ennemie de la france et que la laïcité
c'est l'allié de notre histoire de nos
traditions de nos modes de vie et de nos
coutumes la laïcité fait partie
intégrante des deux mille ans d'histoire
de la france et de l'ensemble de notre
identité
la laïcité ce mail non seulement avec
l'histoire de france et même d'ailleurs
avec l'histoire du christianisme rendez
à dieu ce qui est à dieu et à césar ce
qui est à césar la distinction stricte
entre le temporel et le spirituel entre
le politique et le religieux
c'est aussi ce qui fonde notre
civilisation
la laïcité ce n'est pas la négation ou
la disparition du religieux
c'est une stricte distinction entre
l'ordre politique et l'ordre religieux
et donc ce que nous souhaitons nous à
travers la présence des crèches de noël
c'était le cas ici au siège des
républicains il y a un an
c'est que le conseil d'état puisse
rappeler combien les crèches de noël
comme l'ensemble de nos traditions fonde
l'unité et le rassemblement du peuple
français et nous ne souhaitons pas nous
que le ravi de la crèche puisse devenir
un jour le pas ni en france il est
indispensable que nous puissions
rappeler haut et fort que nos traditions
notre patrimoine notre culture font
partie de manière fondamentale et même
fondatrice de l'histoire de france
nous n'avons pas besoin de ce système
organisé par fois par le microcosme et
les élites
ce système de la repentance et nous nous
préférons à la repentance la célébration
de notre histoire nous croyons
profondément à toutes les filiations
qu'elles soient familiales historique
géographique culturelle nous considérons
nous que la france et la communauté
nationale ne sont pas une addition
d'individus et de consommateurs nous ne
sommes pas des consommateurs nous sommes
avant tout des citoyens et des esprits
libres attachée au pacte républicain et
à la tradition multiséculaire de notre
pays
enfin troisième grand sujet et vous
voyez combien tout ça est intimement
liés que ce soit sur les questions
budgétaires sur les questions de
présence de crèches dans nos bâtiments
publics et nous conclurons avec frédéric
sûr
le traité du ceta vous savez qui fait
l'actualité depuis quelques jours
pourquoi tout cela est lié cellier parce
que c'est le rapport entre le politique
et l'économique dans quelle hiérarchie
la famille des républicains s'inscrit
nous pensons nous à la primauté du
politique sur l'ordre financier et
économique du monde
nous considérons que les états
évidemment on le droit de nouer des
alliances de signer des accords
d'organiser des traités pour organiser
l'économie à une condition stricte c'est
que l'économie soit soumise à la
légitimité du pouvoir politique et sur
la question du ceta nous avons quelques
inquiétudes et entre autres l'une dans
l'est l'une d'entre elles
particulièrement profonde qui pourrait
créer des différents lourd dans l'ordre
des états du monde
c'est la possibilité offerte à des
grands groupes financiers à des
multinationales de se retourner contre
des états souverains qui mettrait en
oeuvre une politique contraire à
l'intérêt des multinationales
qu'est ce que cela veut dire que sur des
questions d'environnement sur des
questions de santé publique sur des
questions de protection des
consommateurs des multinationales
pourraient désormais traîner des états
devant les tribunaux et nous nous
demandons à la fois à travers les
parlements nationaux et à la travers
l'ensemble des rites des dirigeants de
l'union européenne qu'il y ait une
vigilance particulière sur cette
question là donc la question n'est pas
de remettre en cause le ceta sur les
questions de fond on sait que le ceta
apporte quelques avancées entre autres
la protection par exemple des
appellations d'origine française et
européenne
c'est important par exemple que le que
le roquefort soient protégés bien
entendu mais attention que derrière ces
avancées de fonds et de protection de
notre patrimoine gastronomique et
culinaires il n'y ait pas une ambiguïté
est une
soumission du politique à
l'ultralibéralisme le capitalisme
financier comme le mondialisme sauvages
ne sont pas des solutions pour l'avenir
des peuples et le bien-être de nos
économies nous devons avec français
autorités rappelé et c'est tout l'objet
de cette colonne vertébrale que
défendent les républicains c'est que le
pouvoir politique doit l'emporter sur la
finance sur le profit sur le désordre
économique des choses et nous
souhaitions à l'occasion de cette grande
ouverture des négociations via les
parlements nationaux et des discussions
autour du ce et a rappelé la position de
notre famille politique
vous avez là ça veut dire quoi la droite
et la gauche
moi je suis fondamentalement fier d'être
de droite est fondamentalement fier
d'être français
mais si la droite c'est la soumission à
l'ordre établi
c'est la soumission à l'ultralibéralisme
et au mondialisme qui ont entraîné des
ravages en france en europe et dans le
monde
interrogé nos ouvriers nos usines nos
salariés nos agriculteurs alors c'est
une droite dépassé en tout cas c'était
peut-être la droite du 20e siècle la
droite que nous allons devoir réinventer
nous c'est la droite des travailleurs
c'est la droite qui protège les
travailleurs c'est la droite des classes
moyennes
frédéric l'a évoqué tout à l'heure c'est
la ferme conviction que le travail doit
l'emporter sur le capital c'est la ferme
conviction que le politique doit dominer
l'économique
c'est la ferme conviction que tout ne se
vaut pas que tout ne se marchande pas et
qu'il y a quelque chose qui dépasse et
transcende tout c'est la dignité de
l'être humain est ce que c'est le
respect de l'ordre naturel des choses
et cet ordre naturel est bien c'est que
nous sommes très attachés à la liberté
d'entreprendre aux libertés économiques
mais que ce qu'un peuple puisse
envisager de se protéger
contre ces désordres c'est sain et
salutaire et c'est sans doute le grand
enjeu des années qui viennent et c'est
l'enjeu que porte la famille des
républicains de réinventer une droite
qui parle et qui porte la parole des
travailleurs des petits et des faibles
des ouvriers des agriculteurs qui n'en
peuvent plus de cette marche forcée du
monde
on nous présentait la mondialisation
comme forcément heureuse chacun voit
aujourd'hui qu'elle entraîne des ravages
considérables et que par conséquent
cette mondialisation il faut la
contrôler l'organiser et parfois nous en
protéger